Tal Barnoach, thank you so much
for being on my show,
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Good.
Thank you for having me.
Where are you calling from right now?
From my office in Herzliya.
Wonderful
And how is everything over there
with the whole covid situation
and all the protests that are happening?
There is tense.
But in terms of covid,
there were 1,500 cases per day.
There is about 380 in hospitals
that are in more difficult situations.
They're trying to manage it
and to take the numbers down.
Hopefully by September 1st,
when kids are going back to school,
it's going to be much better than now.
Definitely.
And I have to say that
while you hear about covid all the time,
one of the things that I'm really curious
and I'm very excited about,
for this conversation specifically,
is to talk about your journey.
You're currently running
Disruptive Ventures.
But you have a long history
in the tech industry,
all the way from your days
in the intelligence forces,
moving on to creating your own companies.
And being a serial entrepreneur.
I believe you were in some caliber,
another a part of the three,
or four acquisitions, which is just,
I'm sure there's phenomenal stories
from there.
But then moving on
to becoming an angel investor,
now a VC.
And you're on nine different boards.
Tal, I have no idea how you do this.
One of them
is one of my favorite companies,
Tailor Brands.
I'm completely inspired
about what Yali and the team
are doing over there.
So, I love seeing
that you're on their board.
But Tal, let's start easy.
Just give me a little bit of background
about your journey.
Who are you?
Like, why did you do all these things?
It's a great question.
Well, so you know, in Israel,
you have to serve in the army
at the age of 18.
It's compulsory.
So, I did the first few years
from 18 up to 22.
And then obviously in the reserve.
In the Army, I was
in a special intelligence unit.
You can't really talk a lot about it.
But I can say that that was the first time
where someone gave me a real chance.
Because I was pretty junior.
And at the age of between 20, 21,
the head of the unit
called me one day and said,
"There is a guy here that he's rank
about three, four ranks above you,
from tomorrow morning
you're replacing him."
Which was shocking to me.
And I was not prepared.
I had basically the weekend
to mentally and get ready for a new job.
And it was probably Thursday.
And on Sunday, I got in.
I have to manage a lot of people
in very very tough environment
in this unit, in many places.
Tal, I do have to say,
it's something that keeps coming up.
And I believe I heard it first
when Eric Schmidt talked about it,
I think maybe eight years ago
at a conference in Tel Aviv.
And he was talking about this magic
of the startup nation.
That part of it is really this idea that,
at 18 years old,
we entered this army and I'll never forget
coming to the boot camp
and being handed and I'm 16.
And then going through rigorous training
on how to be responsible with it.
And I thought, and I was so confused
that at 18 years old
were given such responsibility.
And the person who was teaching me
how to handle my life responsibly
is a 19 year old
who is just six months above me.
So, what you're talking about,
I think it really resonates.
And that feeling of responsibility
and getting those opportunities
are really remarkable.
But then, how do you transition
from your experience in the IDF onwards
to then, to the real life,
to the startup life?
So, I decided after
that I went to university.
And then I wanted to do my MBA in the US.
And I went to US to get interviewed
in a few good universities.
And then I got a call from someone
that said that he heard about me.
And if I'm willing to come back to Israel
instead of doing my MBA
and start working in manufacturing plant
in the north side of the country.
That at that time was very unique
with unique technology and so forth.
And he said,
"You will make 2,000 shekel."
Which is equivalent today of $600.
Right.
This is what you're going
to make at first.
But if you'd be good
and what I heard about you is true
and you'll be able to gain both experience
and to go up in terms of your salary.
And I decided to come back to Israel.
And I was going five years old every day
from here, Herzliya, Ramat Hasharon
to the north side, which is Karmiel.
So, that's like an hour and a half.
Each one hour 45 minutes each way.
To be exact.
Tal, why did you do this?
In comparison,
any people who are watching this,
and obviously these are maybe
different times,
but it can't be that great of a gap.
Because today,
I enter Stanford in freshman year.
The first question that they ask you is,
"Where do you do your internship
in the summer?"
The second question is,
"How much money are you making?"
One of the greatest pieces of advice
that I've been hearing
is follow your curiosity, not the money.
Because the money will follow.
And I think that that's where
you're alluding to as well.
But I'm thinking, I'm seeing my friends
who are making $6,000
for a summer internship per month.
And you're talking about $600.
Why did you choose
to go to that route?
Because I thought that there is
an amazing opportunity.
I knew that if I will show
that I'm good at what I'm doing,
then I'll be able to go up
and to show them
that I can manage the process.
And yeah, the after five year,
I was making three times
all of my friends what they did.
And I was number two in the company,
and number one [--].
And the company went public.
And then I came to the CEO,
which was the one of the owners.
And I told him,
after we went public, I said,
"Who is going home?"
"You or me?"
So, I was young.
He told me,
"If I wasn't part of the family,
I will go and you should take it."
"But I'm part of the family."
"I can't go anywhere."
"But I really want you to stay."
"I'm willing to offer you
anything you can think about."
But I said,
"No no. I want to be entrepreneur."
"And this time for me to go."
So, I was staying there
for another nine months,
and then I left.
Before you continue
to the next part of the journey,
I want to go back.
When you mentioned first
when you joined the specter,
you talked about the fact
that they have this unique technology
and that it was
an interesting opportunity.
You forwent a big life decision
going to the US, going to do an MBA
to go and work at a factory
in the north of Israel.
This is irregular by any means,
at any point in time.
How big a factor was your curiosity
in driving the technology that was there
or the actual job that you're going to do?
Or was it primarily this idea
that you felt
this could be a good stepping stone
to become a leader in this company?
So yeah. It's I think, it's all of it.
But the first was,
I believe that I can do an impact there.
Second, that if I'll do the right job,
I know that I can become senior
in a position.
And third, I said to myself,
the experience that I will gain there
is unmatched, and for me,
the experience was really important.
I love it.
Okay. So, I'm already taking
a lot of inspiration from that.
And you decide that's just the beginning
of your career in terms of actually
hands on work.
You then go and you work
at a few other startups.
But I want to make sure
we also leave time
to talk a little bit
about your take today.
So, walk me through, now, your transition.
I'll walk you now fast.
The first company is entrepreneur.
It was in the multimedia area
before the Internet.
And with the Israeli chutzpah,
we went to the
International Olympic Committee,
the IOC and to the NBA.
It was Juan Antonio Samaranch,
the IOC president,
and David Stern, the NBA commissioner.
And we got exclusive worldwide rights
for all the Olympics and NBA media.
Why the Israeli chutzpah?
Explain to me that part.
Because two guys out of nowhere
going to convince these guys
that we are the partners
and we are going to do a much better job
than Microsoft and anyone else.
And after eight, nine months
of negotiation,
that literally we had no money whatsoever,
we were sleeping like in small motels,
in different places.
But we came to the meetings with suits
and everything was like.
I love that.
We had to do the show.
So, every time we can,
we show them
that we are an amazing
and might be a big company
and so forth,
when we didn't have
20 bucks in our pocket.
That's beautiful. Wow.
I remember once that we had to,
they called us for immediate meeting.
It was in Rosh Hashanah,
which is the most important holiday,
one of the most important holidays
in Israel and we had to go to Switzerland
and to stay there over for the holiday,
not with the family and so forth.
So, I think that one thing
that is coming out of all of it,
is the commitment.
That once you are committed
to the process, to the project,
to the company, as a founder,
it's a really significant part
of your life and of your success.
How do you measure that today
when you're running Disruptive Ventures
and you're looking
at really great entrepreneurs,
but you're obviously seeing
both the good and the bad.
And I'm guessing that through this lesson,
one of the things you're looking for
is this commitment level, right?
This engagement.
Absolutely. And I'm telling
those entrepreneurs
that coming to me every day, I'm saying,
"Guys, you're going to 10 to 12 years
commitment to a company
that you're going to live, breath."
"All of your life
is going to be around it."
"It's going to be a much less family time,
less friends time."
That's all of that.
But I'm saying that
if it's really into you,
it's in your body, and you decided
that you're going to do it,
nothing will stop you.
And I felt it as entrepreneur.
And I know today
that when I see those guys
that are coming
with the eyes open like this
and they talk about their ideas,
and you see the passion and the energy
and everything else,
you know that you have someone
that you can go with.
So, obviously, one of the big tasks
that that you're faced with
is to differentiate between
artificial passion or theatrical passion
with the real intrinsic passion.
Because I'm guessing especially,
around the world,
a lot of accelerators
and a lot of startup schools,
they teach you how to pitch
and they teach how to present.
And now with my head on
as a senior associate at J-Ventures,
as I'm examining
different early stage startups,
a lot of times I ask myself,
are these people really passionate
about what they're doing
or do they feel like
they're in a Y combinator demo day
that they have to go and scream at me.
Right?
So, is that all intuition?
Or how do you go about and measure
whether somebody is really ready
to make that commitment?
It's you have to meet them
again and again and again.
Right.
And to ask all the questions
that you think that are relevant
to coming from this way,
coming from this way.
And you have to understand.
You have a picture
that you're trying to understand,
the commitment, the level of commitment.
How excited are they about it
and how long they're willing to go
with their passion and dream.
Because if you don't have it,
I think it's the odds
of successful startups
are against those who are starting it.
The statistics.
So, if you don't have the passion
and the energy and everything else,
the odds are much less.
So, you need to have so many things,
so many ingredients into the equation
that the startup will be successful.
That you need to bring some of it
in terms of your body language,
your energy, your passion,
the way you describe it,
and then it will help you.
So, Angel Investments, they sound great.
I get to talk
to quite a few angel investors
and it seems like it's living the life,
working out of coffee shops
and meeting great entrepreneurs.
Why form a VC?
Why form Disruptive Ventures?
And what is Disruptive Ventures?
What is the mission there?
So, Disruptive.
We started Disruptive because,
so I was entrepreneurial and then angel,
and then I started Disruptive.
And Disruptive, I said to myself that
there is a vacuum
between the seed stage and round A.
We called it seed plus.
I heard many talk about this.
It's like the power seed round.
That people need this extra. Yeah.
And in Israel at the time,
there was no scale between there.
So, what was happening
when I started Disruptive,
there was so many companies
that got seed money
but couldn't go up to the A-round
because they left with no money
after the half a million dollars
to a million dollars they got.
And then they was not ready
for the A-round.
So I said, I will tackle this place
between the seed and the round A.
And I will invest in those companies.
Will give them the
one to two million dollars
to help them go to the A-round.
So, that was the thesis behind it.
Why Disruptive?
Because I really believe
that the Israeli entrepreneurs
have to come with disruption,
ideas, technologies, products,
business model and so forth,
to compete with all
of the global companies out there.
Whether they are in Silicon Valley,
in the East Coast, in Europe,
in Asia and so forth.
Because we are nine million people country
and we have to think global
from the get go.
If you don't come
with the real disruption,
if you don't change
the way people consume product,
work with product,
come with innovation,
do something that is really different,
it will be very difficult to compete
those companies there.
I love it.
By the way, Tal, just to make sure
that when you're talking about
that the stage where you are investing,
are you just adding on to the seed round
or are you a bridge round
between the seed and series A generally?
Sometimes I will write the seed check.
But it will be a bigger check
than the usual one.
And sometimes it will be the bridge
between the seed and round A.
I'm now doing my third fund,
which called disruptive AI.
Which is the junction between disruption
and AI technology.
I brought a new team
to help me with disruptive AI.
Adi, was the second in command in 8200.
Gadi, that was a general partner in JVP.
And professor [--]
from Bar-Ilan University,
which have the biggest AI lab
in the country.
So, we formed a group of people
that will do investments in the junction
between disruption and AI,
which I think it's the way to go
when you move forward.
When you look at the next 10 years,
AI is going to be a very important
part of our life in general.
For the things that we're going to do,
behave and so forth.
And the fact that now
because of big data
and because of you can
really get a lot of information
that you couldn't get before,
it's really helping you
to form those companies.
So, we're really excited about it.
100%. And Tal,
we have just a few minutes.
But I have to get your input.
You're a board member
of eight or nine companies right now.
Which I have no idea
how you're juggling all those.
Give me your two cents
about the responsibilities
of being a board member.
What do you enjoy most
about this experience?
Or what is your responsibility
as a board member there?
So, I'll be very honest here.
And I know that I'm a bit different
from other people.
Board is not important.
Okay.
What is important is the work
that you do with the entrepreneur,
all year long, every month,
every week, every day.
Board is a summary
of what's happening up to now
and what you forecast for the future.
But we work with the entrepreneurs
all the time.
So, I know before the board
what will be in the board meeting.
I want to prepare myself
for this board meeting.
And I think that, I'm always saying that
because I work with young entrepreneurs,
you mentioned Yali.
But there is Yali and David
and Danielle and all of those guys.
I'm a psychology.
I'm just not charging for it.
I love it.
So, those guys are coming to me
all the time.
And they have problems here
and they have problems there.
And it's a roller coaster.
And one day they think
that they're the next Google.
And the day after, Oh, my God,
they going bust.
And you need to really be helpful for them
and understand what, where they are.
And give them a hug.
And when you need to be tough, be tough.
But really, I think that
it's the whole enchilada
that you're really supporting them
and giving them your help
and empathy and sympathy
to help them really go
through the tough times.
The board is the other side of it.
Means that you really come
to a two hours meeting,
[--] with people.
You get the summary from the company.
You decide where you're going.
You help them lead the next quarter or so.
But I think the really important work
is what you do in between
and not those.
Tal, completely inspiring.
I just love it.
But before we leave,
and by the way,
I have to mention that I can't wait
to share with you a slide
that hopefully in the coming years,
as I go on my own entrepreneurial journey.
But before that,
I need three words from you.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself,
or that any of your founders
that work with you on the day to day
would describe you as.
Focused.
Okay.
Persistent.
And friendship.
Focused, persistent and friendship.
I love it. And obviously I didn't give you
time to prepare,
but I think that those three words
are already exuding
through the whole conversation
that we had.
So, Tal, I want to thank you again
for your generous time.
And I know how busy you are.
I think you have about nine board meetings
to attend to now.
And more companies to invest in.
So, thank you very much. Toda raba.
Thank you, Michael.
Thanks.
Take care